Speaker 1: . This is probably my favorite Joe
Biden moment from his presidency thus far. And
it came during yesterday's White House
event where outdoors at the White House,
Joe Biden announced the CDC has new guidelines.
We have been vaccinating enough and the vaccines
are so effective that masking outdoors is no
longer necessary for vaccinated people in most
situations. This was a great announcement.
This was really a sign of progress.
And Joe Biden did walk out to that event
wearing his mask. He took it off to speak
and he announced masks are no longer
necessary outdoors for vaccinated people.
He was a vaccinated person outdoors, taking
off his mask. And Peter Alexander from NBC News
was just desperate. You could see desperate to
generate controversy. I've talked before about
how in the absence of real scandals, the likes
of which we saw during the Trump administration,
under Biden reporters, even reporters that
generally are just asking good questions,
they are just beside themselves to figure out
some controversy, some gotcha against Joe Biden.
So Peter Alexander from NBC News eager to ask
a question about Joe Biden's mask. Joe Biden
first putting on his sunglasses, not his
mask, and saying he will take a couple of
questions, one at a time, but.
Speaker 2: I one at a time.
Speaker 1: So then here is the question from
Peter Alexander. Sir, you came out with a mask,
but you're saying masks aren't necessary.
Explain that, isn't that a double standard,
isn't it? Why would you wear the mask
if the announcement is that they're
not necessary? Here is Joe Biden's answer.
Speaker 2: And you chose to wear a mask and
you chose to wear a mask if you chose
to wear a mask as you walked out here.
What message were you sending by wearing a mask
outside alone and watching me take it off? And
I put it back until I got inside.
Speaker 3: Do you have any proof?
Speaker 1: This is just hilarious. I mean. Well,
when I came out with the mask, I hadn't yet
announced the new mask guidelines. I took the
mask off and announced them. And now I'm not
putting the mask back on because I've explained
why to the American people it's just so petty and
so embarrassing. And then Fox News reported on the
question being asked, like asking Biden about this
and noticing his mask is some kind of hypocrisy.
This is now Fox News after the event saying,
oh, yeah, lots of people were noticing that,
Speaker 3: but he didn't do well. He walked from
the White House alone wearing the mask to the
podium. And, of course, there was something we
noticed right away. And now, yeah, of course,
you look at your social media, that's what
everyone's talking about, just overjoyed.
Speaker 1: They are over at Fox News
about Peter Alexander, a reporter from another
network, just kind of being made a fool of
just having a grant. They really got him
there, didn't they? And the other thing is
that even the framing of all this is wrong.
The lower third on Fox News during that clip
was Biden relaxes outdoor mask guidelines. Biden
has done nothing. The CDC has relaxed outdoor mass
guidelines and Joe Biden listens to the public
health experts. This is not a trivial difference
between the Trump administration and the Biden
administration. Trump would often come up with
his own ideas that had nothing to do with public
health, official guidance on masking, on maybe
injecting bleach on with a flu vaccine deal with
coronavirus. And remember that beauty towards the
beginning of the pandemic and on and on and on.
Biden has done nothing. Biden has just announced,
hey, great news because of what we've all been
doing together, vaccinating ourselves and so on.
The CDC has now been able to announce this. And
I'm glad to let you know that this is what they've
decided. The whole framing is off. The forced
laughter in the clip clip is deeply bizarre.
Everything about this is strange and pathetic.
And now the other totally hypocritical
and transparent thing is all this time they've
been saying, don't make me wear a mask,
which really they should be saying to their
governors, not Biden. Remember Joe Biden. It's
up to Joe Biden past a federal mask mandate in
the sense that it applies to federal buildings
and federal employees and so on and so forth.
Governors at the state level decide on state level
mask mandates. The CDC makes recommendations. Joe
Biden can amplify those recommendations, but it's
really governors. But you've got these people
have been saying, do not make me wear a mask
now that Joe Biden says, hey, great news.
The CDC is now OK with no more masks outside
for vaccinated people. In most situations, they're
still not happy. Now, the problem is, well,
why did Biden wear his mask on his way out to say
this? The last guy wondered aloud about injecting
or drinking bleach, and they're making fun
of Joe Biden for wearing his mask to a mask
related announcement. As I've been saying for
weeks now, when these are the controversies,
when this is what Fox News is focused on, Joe
Biden is probably on the right track in terms
of just keeping his head down and doing things
and avoiding scandals. Do we want him doing more
things? Of course. Do we think everything
he's doing is perfect? No, of course not.
But when the scandals are so pathetic, fake news
about meat eating and plant based beer on and on
Joe Biden and Joe Biden's relationship is stage
managed, whatever, when those are the scandals,
he's avoiding real scandals, that's for sure.
We will have more on the new mask guidelines.
And again, there are people in the audience that
are mad about the new mass guidelines. They seem
eminently reasonable and they aren't, that you
can't wear a mask if you want. If if you aren't
vaccinated, the guidelines are still wear a mask
outdoors. And even if you are and you just want to
wear a mask, you can. It's sort of like my example
from the Tucker episode. If you want to wear a
winter hat in the middle of summer, go ahead and
do it. I think that these are eminently reasonable
new guidelines and that they will hopefully
encourage some more people to get vaccinated.
We'll have reaction from you on our Instagram
account. Follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman show. We'll take a quick break.
The Joe Rogan anti vaccine claims coming up next.